it's been a little while since the
astros have seen the san diego padres
but that face should be familiar even
with the mustache on it garrett richards
has faced the astros a lot in his career
15 games 12 starts most of those all of
those as a los angeles angel of anaheim
he's moving south putting on the pin
stripes and has a 3.45 era
in the father's uniform and it brings up
jose altuve the second baseman batting
190 248 on base percentage three homers
now tuve first pitch swinging line drive
past the shortstop cronenworth into left
field springer held up and there you go
the 1-2 punch comes through
and the astros have runners at the
corners with nobody out
correa hits it on a line that's a base
hit into left field finding a hole
between cronenworth and machado the
astros on the board early one nothing
boy what a great start hit it hard right
on the button again through the left
side of the infield it's not easy to get
it by machado at third astros on the
board and still nobody out three
straight hits to start this game and a
quick run now for houston so this will
load the bases on the first free pass
served up by richards of his outing and
more pitches and a visit from his
pitching coach he is set runners start
to go swing get him strike three
guess what catching a ball game right
here he came back with that same slider
he wanted to get to him there wipeout
time swinging a minute so he gets a
couple of strikeouts vince mccullers jr
on the mound for the astros well
bouncing back from tommy john's surgery
back in 2018 makes his sixth start a
lead runner on here for the padres in
the bottom of the first inning is
fernando tatis jr who tonight is the dh
on the ground sharply hit to third toro
go to second for one on to first that's
two tatis grounds into the five four
three around the horn dp and that'll
bring up manny machado
machado hits under the ground up the
middle and by the dive of correa a round
from second comes hosmer he will score
and the padres have tied the game one to
one manny machado driving in the game
tying run right back up the middle for
machado that'll work a two out rbi just
playing a little game of pepper right
there just below the belt buckle and
beating the defense of correa just out
of the shortstop's reach so straw moves
to third springer's at second now two
ways at first and now it's correa he had
an rbi single his first time up base is
loaded for the second inning in a row
for the astros
swing and a miss and he struck him out
that is strikeout number three for
richards and two down here in the second
inning that's a doozy right there
ace is still loaded and josh redick 63
pitches 35 of them for strikes so far
for richards that hat is drenched yes it
is
another 3-2 count and another pitch by
garrett richards swinging in a miss
strike three
still a ball game what a veteran my gosh
you think guys in the clubhouse don't
see this and respect guys like that it's
tatis on second hosmer on first base for
machado mccullar is working hard now the
pitch curve ball and that's hit right at
toro at third he goes to altuve at
second on the first double play
what a turn and what a moment for the
astro as mccullers pumps his fist and
that'll do it for san diego here in the
third will myers the batter
look out that is a breaking ball that
backs into the helmet of will myers he
ducked down
and as he was losing his helmet that
pitch hit him he had nowhere to go that
get him in the back of the head
checking out his gear make sure it's
okay a very successful sacrifice punt by
greg garcia now the astros bring the
infield in against the switch hitter
jerks in profile
in the air to left field tucker going
back towards the track and tucker leaps
and makes the catch tagging in third is
cronenworth he will score
and tying it second and moving to third
is myers as the padre is taking a 2-1
lead on a sac fly for turrets of profar
in a very nice catch as you mentioned by
tucker out there two down in the fifth
and manny machado machado lines it into
left field for a base hit grisham coming
around trying to score the throw from
tucker is going to be cut off and the
padres take a 3-1 lead manny machado
driving in a run for san diego
second hit second rbi tonight for manny
machado from the worth has done the same
thing twice tonight that's watts
mccullars jr has been very careful in
dealing with him
in the air to right field springer going
back at the wall that ball is going to
be off the wall
machado is going to try and score all
the way from first base here's the throw
it will be
not in time machado's in and the padres
take a 4-1 lead
wall ball double for jake cronenworth
drives in manny machado all the way from
first and the padres lead it four to one
nice job running nice job sliding by
machado who ends up going feet first
into the plate umpire and then hugging
his leg
wanna bring up miles straw who is one
for two with an infield hit oh one and
that's hammered deep to left field it
sends back profile at the wall he can't
get it it's off the wall around third
jones he will score straw will take the
turn at second and stop there with an
rbi double and it is four to two padres
boy straw almost took him deep that's
back-to-back doubles now for the astros
i thought straw got him the padres who
had four grand slams in four consecutive
games have the bases loaded here with
two outs in the sixth inning and eric
hosmer did it last night can he do it
again the one two and that's grounded
hits off the glove of perez feel it by
correa spins foes got him at first oh
what a play by correa perez tipped that
with his glove slowed it down correa
fielded it behind second did a pirouette
and able to get hosmer to get the astros
out of the inning so it continues for
the left-handed hitting left fielder
kyle tucker who's already walked twice
tonight here's the pitch
and it is lined into center field and
that's a base hit a one hopper to
grisham altuve's gonna score toro around
second and makes it to third on the rbi
single by tucker and now the astros are
within one run it's four to three
that'll give abraham toro a chance
on the ground softly towards second base
it is garcia the first of the padres win
tonight they beat the astros 4-3 good
way to start this three-game weekend
series